do that how girls always stick out their
tongue in the video are they trying to
lick their other girlfriends like let's
take a picture hi why don't you explain
to me why you always do this you see I
was the one you always do I have every
[ __ ] picture you do this you go let's
take a selfie of our faces you better
have your [ __ ] isn't really drunk or
[ __ ] ugly is that why is it cuz your
other oh we don't have to peck for your
pen no wear pants shirts jackets are you
gonna wear
I'm pretty layered with my natural body
fat so I'm not sure if I need extra
layers buttered ah scarf do you wear
skirt
I have no neck so when I wear a scarf I
look like a floating head I look like a
pile of laundry with a head lock chopped
off arm we're gonna go on a day when you
come back okay okay
I was pretty funny I don't I don't have
another I just want to feel better
listen everybody has a look or number
that's what I find out huh
so what are you going for try get off
did not a sinner he's good
when I walk into a room ever what the
hell I didn't get to finish my sentence
you gonna shoot me down like that hold
on a second when I walk into it what I
want listen well I dare it when I walk
into a room I want everybody to lose
their virginity
if I become a good-looking man it's just
not fair for the world you know your
face doesn't change really if you like I
do beautiful this is the moneymaker you
don't know because it's covered with six
chins it's actually one big one Cassey
ho mm-hmm that's a very unfortunate last
name for Korean or Chinese
you just say everything just go
throughout all Cambodia Laos Asian
Southeast Asia did you say everything in
your engine like people black people my
pen in the end oh what's up you guys um
I um ha it is the night before I'm
supposed to go to Japan man I have been
packing my hair song I got to tell you
this has been a a rough rough week
before leaving Japan now mind you I had
Thanksgiving dinner I cooked that all
from scratch while doing a video a brand
deal and everything else so it's just
been really rough but kind of happy
because next week I am putting up a blog
where I'm thrown out of La the video
sketch called sneakerheads what you got
will probably already have seen
oh we're weird but they're your only
shoes there's your favorite yeah and
what do you have a room full of sneakers
that you haven't worn the [ __ ] is all
this but I know that it's gonna be fun
because I'm with my friends I personally
don't like traveling alone I hate
traveling alone because it's just it's
sad man like you just want to share
these experience and memories with other
people there's nobody to share it with
so you just you know stay in your rooms
you jackoff
yeah but tomorrow hopefully will be a
good day I got to wake up early deposit
some checks do some errands before I
bounce then off I go to Japan I heard
I'm like a sumo over there
Josh you got the biggest feet on earth
dude just crazy man gifted if you hit
you got baby feet next to win it is
that's crazy dude
if you kick somebody you would literally
kick them from the top of there next to
theirs bottom of the crotch look at
their whole torso Todd are you excited
for Japan
yeah super excited super excited because
I like Asian countries I love Asian
culture pieces um what I hear like Japan
is like if you love a city at the
cassini on your breath noth-nothing
people are crackheads I feel like you're
excited because you're gonna buy a lot
of things no I'm not a big time shopper
I get tired really fat is gonna show me
yeah the way you were talking about
Japan made it seem like you wanted to
shop I do because of just the unique
apparel that they have in shoes that we
don't have
but they're so tiny over there they're
gonna have your size 100% sure you're
not gonna be able to buy anything a
paralyzed he's going to try to look for
some watch he knows a hundred percent of
these and I've been hit with he's still
look tries it on to these I'm [ __ ]
pissed in here I'm like
Oh whoever thinks about picking up a
child by their backpacks first of all I
didn't miss nothing
all right and second of all you are
beautiful how did you did you were you
born this way your eyes are sparkling
and by the way can I tell you something
can I tell you see you eight o'clock and
I'm like hey David good morning tape is
on its way to go pick you up at eight
twelve thirteen I'm like David P Z there
wake up oh my god David wake up nice
early they're blowing up his phone Oh
texting on like calling in like crazy
baby and then you know we're not
addressing the real problem though what
is the real problem the real problem is
why are you so pretty today that's the
best response in the world there's
something about you today I don't know
what it is but I'm gonna let KC know
that he should let you know how
beautiful you are
I am so she's clock it keep going
and that was the last time I'm gonna
give him [ __ ] and I forgive you
Hey but Gina showed up an hour late she
doesn't count cause she already told her
she wasn't gonna come with us with the
shuttle you know what I was too busy
trying to make your birthday gift I
couldn't bring it because you rushed me
out so I mean I guess it's cool though
whatever you have to wait another two
weeks for it um I'm just saying you
might wake up with a huge gift next deal
is Casey's penis enlargement